hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ich habe euch bei instagram
gefragt ob irgendwelche fragen an mich
habt und ihr konntet ihr unter einem
bild von mir was ich dort hochgeladen
habe stellen da kamen sehr viele fragen
an und die beantwortung von jetzt ein
paar wegen fangen märchen direkt an mit
dem kranken wie stehst du zu apfelsaft
ich mag apfelsaft auf jeden fall lieber
als tomatensaft sitz für einen roten
knopf wenn du ihn drückt bekommst du
eine million euro aber irgendeine person
auf der ganzen welt still wenn du den
knopf nicht drückst wirst du sterben
wird es zu drücken also ich meine wenn
ich nicht drücke sterbe ich und wenn ich
drücke steht wegen der anderen person
und ich bekomme eine million euro also
natürlich will ich drücken
jeder würde drücken wie wir es mit einer
modelkarriere ich hab schon vier fünf
anfragen bekommen aber das ist was das
da verkauft man seinen körper komplett
und das ist überhaupt nicht mein ding
nur in opa wärs willst du mit youtube
weiter machen auf jeden fall also ich
denke mein content wird dann anders
aussehen aber solange es mir spaß macht
mache ich das noch was ist dein
wunschauto das tesla model s p 90 d das
ist ein elektroauto falls du mir zu
hause
ich habe mir diese beiden neuen sorten
wie lou gekauft weil ich dazu eigentlich
ein video machen wollte aber mir ist
nichts richtiges ein gefallen deswegen
wenn ihr den habt schreibt in den
kommentaren oder rot rot
wie kommst du deine schwester
kennengelernt liga ist ist meine
schwester wie soll ich sie kennengelernt
habe wenn du dich besser meine erste
freundin ein oder anderen erstes auto
definitiv mein erstes auto
magst du mich ja ich mag eigentlich
jeden von euch was würdest du machen
wenn du ein youtube star oder so sehen
würdest ich würde mich komplett normal
verhalten und wahrscheinlich mit ihm
über youtube reden lieblings pizzabelag
scheiß egal ob pizza wenn du nur deinen
besten freundin hat einen vater zur
auswahl hast wen würde strecken mein
vater weil ich dem einfach viel näher
stehe als jedem freund der jemand freund
sein wird oder gewesen ist dann packt
seine lieblingstiere eigentlich schon
immer also ich kann mich an keine zeit
erinnern wo ich nicht geantwortet hätte
das alpakas meine lieblingstiere sind
dann kommt mal wieder einen treffer port
video wenn ihr mir sagt was ich den
clever bot fragen soll dann demnächst
also text ist das doch vielleicht auch
einfach mal die kommentare wie oft
spielt zu minecraft weise einfach so
ohne aufnehmen
also eigentlich tatsächlich nie wenn ich
mein kreft nicht aufnehmen welchen
youtuber schaffst du aktiver kein ich
mache youtube-videos aber ich konsumiere
keine anderen
videos gibt es momente wo du nicht
berühmt erkannt sein werden wolltest
eigentlich so zu jedem moment also mich
bewegt das eigentlich total auf dieses
ganz erkannt werden also wenn die leute
zu mir hinkommt nach dem foto fragen
jetzt klar aber wenn leute einfach nur
neben meinem stehen und kichern und
einen verfolgenden ist es einfach nur
noch weg ist das schon einmal
sitzengeblieben nein ich war mal kurz
davor früher eine klasse zu überspringen
aber ich bin noch nicht sitzengeblieben
es ist ein traum reiseziel für dieses
jahr hier zu hause bei meiner familie
sein und das leben genießen ich habe gar
keinen bock zu reisen weil das immer so
stressig ist ich habe eigentlich schon
relativ viel gesehen also in europa war
ich fast überall in amerika war schon in
new york und ich finde jetzt diese
ganzen asiatischen städte reizt mich
nicht das einzige würde ich doch gerne
hin wollen würde wäre barcelona und san
francisco bundes zu shoppen aus einem
geschäft rausgeschmissen nein noch nie
vor hast doch meist lang dass ich
menschen verliere die mir sehr nahe
stehen also enge bekannte freunde und
familie davor sich tatsächlich mehr als
von meinem eigenen tod welche neuen
freunde hast du bei youtube
kennengelernt mit denen wir jetzt sehr
gut befreundet bist gar kein also ich
habe über youtube sehr viele leute
kennengelernt aber keinen würde ich
jetzt wirklich als freund bezeichnen
also es sind einfach nur so
arbeitskollegen wenn man das über
gewissen form so nennen haben wir zeit
bis 1 kind als kind sein ist genauso zu
hause wie es jetzt aussieht
das hat sie eigentlich nicht verändert
desto mal ein haustier meine mutter
hatte mal schildkröten also waren das in
einer gewissen form dann auch meine
haustiere aber so ein richtiges haustier
das nur mir gehört hatte hatte ich mal
ein löwenkopf zwergkaninchen namens
krümmel und wir hatten noch ein zweites
dass dies klappt allerdings klopfer
gestorben haben wir kommen abgegeben
damit nicht allein sein sollte
der tragische geschichte zwischen adobe
oder bibi palace auslesen könntest
würdest du als freundin nehmen definitiv
da die also ich weiß nicht was man dann
baby findet ich kenne sie persönlich
nicht vom aussehen her ist es überhaupt
nicht mein typ da die auch er nicht aber
ich mich entscheiden müsste dann erst
die konflikt und dann nämlich und
andersrum definitiv erst die cornflakes
und dann die milch sonst was ja gar
nicht wieviel mich voll rein tun muss
finden 1 tier wiedergeboren werden für
welches tier wüsste gerne sein werden
ihm einen kompletten leben eine
komplette wohnung beziehungsweise
haustür machen weil wir das einfach viel
zu privat ist ich könnte euch allerdings
dieses zimmer hier zeigen dass mein kind
heinz zimmer oder halt mein aufnahme
zimmer also wenn ihr davon was wollt
dann schreibt man die kommentare
freundlich eine freundin
das ist genauso ein thema wie meine
komplette wohnung oder was ich studiere
dass es einfach ultra privaten möchte
ich nicht beantworten wie machst du
deine haare eigentlich nicht so
schwierig was die halt einfach und dann
fündig die trocken und da mag ich wachs
rein und wenn es dann nicht hält er noch
haarspray also wenn ihr wollt kann ich
euch das sommer ein video machen oder so
aber er schreibt dass meine kommentare
ist verschreibt voll viele die
kommentare diesmal oder hast du dir
mädchen richtung seitz fans bei youtube
ist es glaube ich relativ ausgeglichen
so der anteil von jungs und mädchen bei
instagram merke ich dass es irgendwie
viel mehr mädchen sind und irgendwie bei
snap chat sieht man ja gar nicht wer
irgendwann ist wurst oder käse definitiv
wurst ab studierst du die vorhin schon
gesagt wird dass mit zu den sachen die
relativ privat sind und über die ich
nicht reden möchte aber sage ich euch
gleich nach dem studium möchtest du
lieber ein gegenmittel viele krankheiten
finden oder lieber superstar werden ich
glaube wer sich dafür superstar
entscheidet es irgendwie hart auf den
kopf gefallen also ich werde definitiv
lieber der erfinder eines gegenmittels
für alle krankheiten
wahrscheinlich wird man deswegen hat
einfach auch ein superstar machst du
mein video mit julien beim zusammen
hätte ich bock drauf weiß ich aber nicht
weil ich eigentlich gar keine videos mit
anderen youtuber machen würdest du mit
max zusammen sein wenn deine eltern vor
der krippe stehen und sie nur retten
kannst wenn du mit max vier jahre
zusammen sein muss auf jeden fall
ich meine man kann ja auch zusammen sein
ohne sich zu küssen also max es nicht
schwul ich bin nicht schwul und um meine
eltern zu retten welche geben menschen
auf der welt vier jahre lang zusammen
ist die mal hier und nach hause gefolgt
ja und ich sage euch das ist das
schlimmste gefühl auf der welt wenn du
einfach weißt du gehst nach hause zu
einem privaten ort und fans in
hintergrund verfolgen dich das ist so
ekelhaft bitte macht das einfach nicht
wie gehst du mit deinem strike ich habe
keinen streit mehr der ist weg
allerdings ist das video auch weg das
ist bisschen traurig wenn du dich
entscheiden wird ist blind oder taub ich
würde mich an der stelle auf jeden fall
führt auf entscheiden weil ich glaube
ich würde mich besser fühlen wenn ich
noch sehen können anstatt zu hören als
wenn ich nur noch hören konnte
bist du schon viele freundinnen ein
freundinnen so richtige beziehungen
nicht hättest du mal wenn du könntest
zum mond fliegen auf gar keinen fall aus
sah ich könnte ein paar leute mitnehmen
weil so wenn man alleine zum mond
fliegen würde wieder zurück dass das
dann wird man wenn man einfach komplett
allein und das kann ich nicht ich kann
wirklich nicht allein sein ich hatte so
was würdest du machen wenn an einem tag
alles erlaubt wäre ich würde mich
genauso verhalten wie rainald an
sonntagen bis zu die tattoo stechen
lassen auf gar keinen fall was trinkst
du mal bei starbucks einen cappuccino
ohne kaffee aber mit sahne
wie bist du eigentlich zu mein name ist
luca gekommen weil es mein name ist das
ist der grund ist eine hamburger dabei
auf gar keinen fall kommentiere neue
bücher oder was komplett anderes
zunächst einmal kommen wir diese beiden
t shirts bald in denen minister von de
die kommen da zusammen rein mit einem
kissen allerdings ist bücher technisch
jetzt so erstmal nichts geplant und wenn
ich noch ein buch herausbringen solcher
definitiv nicht über minecraft sondern
über irgendwas anderes
das war es mit dem video meine damen und
herren ich weiß nicht ob es genau 50
fragen waren ich glaube es waren eher so
48 weil ich habe während des aufnehmens
noch zwei fragen rausgenommen die gar
keinen sinn ergeben haben oder die ich
doppelt gespendet haben oder so ich
hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen was
haltet ihr davon soll ich so was man
öfter machen dass ich auf instagram sage
hat mir fragen nicht beantwortet die so
schnell nicht kann und ihr habt
informationen und nicht nur unterhaltung
vielleicht gefällt solcher ich würde
mich über eine bewertung freuen und wir
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder und
folgend mir auf instagram damit ihr bei
solchen situationen und aktionen direkt
bescheid wisst ich heiße der laser luca